hey you want to feel really good about
yourself
i got you you can go hey yeah i'm a
piece of pooper
but at least i'm not this guy this is
tony geraldo
[Music]
is going to have the biggest biceps in
the world bro bro pause it pause it
tell me that does not look like
[Music]
tell me that does not look like this
let's go
oh man
tell me why
[Music]
i don't know anything about this this is
all new to me but apparently it's
synthol which is basically oil as far as
i understand uh site enhancement oil
it's also a french brand of mouthwash
a recent trend in bodybuilding is to
inject synthol into muscles to create
larger bulges or injecting pmma acrylic
glass
excuse me excuse me into muscles to
shape them use pmma to shape muscles
it's prohibited in the united states
however it is not illegal to use synthol
it's side enhancement oil that's what it
is oh my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
yeah you
you think you may have just pushed it a
little too far
you know it's kind of like fake boobs
you know okay they always go overboard
it looks silly it looks stupid you got a
little nicer little
okay all right
maybe that's the same with synthol
because this is so funny
so he's going to a doctor
his arms are too heavy it's almost like
he doesn't have the muscle
like that shouldn't be a problem if
you're having muscles that your arms are
too heavy right
that's the problem that takes care of
itself
it's a problem with the spine i mean
man's got man boobs too uh i don't know
what this guy is on bro
uh
how is this a trend this cannot be a
trend i refuse to believe this is a
trend
she doesn't like it it's not like
anyone's pushing you to do this tony
you don't regret
bro you have a sure illness
okay you understand i take the physique
of this guy in the back over you any day
dude anyone actually in the back had to
take the physique over you okay so you
can buy this up the internet but it's
purely uh
it's not like you're building muscle
it's purely cosmetic it can cause
pe which is blockage in the artery in
the lungs great nerve damage infection
yeah yeah this just looks bad imagine if
if you get oh god infection oh
stroke oh do i dare to even look
oh no started bodybuilding years ago he
had dreams of becoming a
bro it all went down to his oh but man
he's got a band-aid he's good he's good
we're you're good we got banding
do not google it do not google it don't
show that that's that's too gross as a
result of abusing the process tyresian
would have dead flesh removed from his
arms and face the risk of dead amputates
it's like rotten synthol is often
characterized as a muscle building
steroid but it's actually entirely
different
anabolic steroids work in a manner
similar to testosterone and increase
protein within cells particularly in
skeletal muscles synthol is mainly made
up of oil with low concentrations of
lidocaine and alcohol it's injected into
muscle strictly for cosmetic purposes
right
strictly cosmetic i've already undergone
severe trauma and may have become
infected as a result of being
overwhelmed by the oil result of hyphens
oh bro
it's like they took the liquifier tool
on photoshop and was like yeah that
looks good as he faced irreparable nerve
damage and even amputation regardless
sagato was entirely committed to his
dangerous lifestyle and used the social
media handle
[Music]
that is not real you did not look like
that reputation he had as a monster oh
my god
stop it oh bro he lost his arm that's
horrible desousa became addicted he grew
to an abnormal mass that earned him a
reputation in his hometown of olinda
where he was nicknamed the mountain his
muscles became so large that they were
deformed and unnaturally can't make
however his strength hadn't increased as
the man maintained the same workout
regime
eventually stopped him i'm sure
underneath there's real gains to be made
this is why you don't skip brain day
men's body dysmorphia needs to be
recognized as a problem more often i
agree i'm surprised how i never heard
about this before you only really see it
in women
shoulder leaking
no
look look at his shoulder
look at his shoulder
no
that is not real
oh god it's going down
i'll be back just get some duct tape
[Music]
meet the real live hulks
my body attracts women very much
sure they do of course they do
why wouldn't they
uh all the women in the comments right
now yeah
bodies beyond belief
it looks like muscle but we don't know
why we just don't know we just don't
know the science isn't there to
determine yet what is injecting their
muscles with oil i looked in the mirror
and i felt good about myself
yeah basically drugs are not meant to be
in the body two doctors are on i feel
like i don't need a doctor to tell me
that's not a good
that's not good two doctors are on a
mission bro he did not he doesn't do his
legs look
i mean
maybe that's good that he doesn't i
don't know but like
are on a mission to stop this lethal
craze it's becoming such a big problem
around the world they re oh my god do
you see how skinny is actually a risk
limbs let me see your arm that's not
gonna heal
stop life stop
his wrist he hasn't done anything i need
to get him to stop injecting i don't
know if i'll be able to accomplish that
i'm really really nervous that i can't
get him to
oh gee
the first results that we got were your
blood tests i'm a little bit concerned
with what we're saying here
i love this moment it always comes up
when people do crazy it's like
i'm going to die
this was never told to me
i'm slowly killing myself that's normal
muscle
he has no normal muscle left
this
all of this
this pure product that you've injected
it's eaten up and taken over your entire
muscle oh my god much more severe
than i've seen in the other two cases
[Music]
bro
now i feel bad almost don't make me feel
bad i am not looking at the gross stuff
no sir he told me that the body is
reacting i have to hope and be lucky now
but the wound has gotten worse
we have a whole new area now that we
didn't see yesterday so as you can see
the body's really starting to react we
have the arm we have these two areas the
oil just doesn't want to be there
anymore
he
swore to me that he will no longer
inject but what happens in the future is
totally up to volunteer god
valjer's only hope for better health is
to stop injecting oh my god i am i am i
am
speechless i don't know what after this
i have a second chance to start again
it's never too late for games my dude
it's never too late mom can we get
steroids we have steroids at home so
yeah both of them are from brazil i
think
it sounds like it what's up with that i
don't know
so there's this russian guy who wanted
to prove his actual muscles that he
actually had the strength
by doing a one-armed pull-up
and this is completely fake
are you serious oh
oh man
bruh
wow you're so strong it's a version of
synthol that looks good shirley
bro
promise me
promise me none of y'all [ __ ]
ever do this no i ban you i ban all of
this i ban it i banished it
[Music]
well that was the dumbest i ever seen i
hope you enjoyed if you did smash like
check out merch oh wait you came sold
out [ __ ]
see you next time bye bye profess